Générique
...
Musique trépidante
-Deux mois après le lancement
d'une opération militaire
dans le sud d'Arnland
pour stabiliser la région
et stopper les exactions
des milices Tantale,
le pays fait aujourd'hui face
à une offensive Mercure
qui fait craindre le pire.
-Nuit de terreur
dans l'est d'Arnland
après d'intenses...
-On pourrait y croire,
mais ces journaux
télévisés sont fictifs,
créés pour un exercice militaire,
baptisé Orion,
le plus important réalisé
sur le sol français depuis 30 ans.
Imaginé il y a trois ans,
cet entraînement
interarmées et interalliés
se déroulait en France début 2023
dans plus de 20 départements
avec près de 20 000 militaires
mobilisés au total.
L'objectif :
se préparer à l'éventualité
d'une guerre moderne,
pouvant aller
jusqu'à la haute intensité,
une perspective
qui ne relève plus
de la science-fiction,
alors que la guerre a fait
son retour en Europe.
Plongez avec nous dans les coulisses
de cet exercice hors normes.
-Brief sur le concept d'opération
pour l'entrée en premier
dans la troisième dimension,
opération aéroportée,
qui se déroulera
dans la zone de H-Castres.
-Donc moi, je donne le vert
maintenant et, après,
c'est comme à l'OTAN,
procédure de silence.
Je fais simplement un contrôle,
les deux composantes se parlent
et on revient vers moi si,
à un moment donné,
on a un doute ou qu'on a besoin
que je confirme quelque chose,
mais à partir du moment
où la situation tactique
et la situation météo
sont sur le trait
que vous m'avez décrit,
c'est vert, en avant.
On sort un peu de ce qu'on fait
depuis 20 ans,
on est dans une autre
échelle de guerre,
dans un autre tempo d'opérations,
donc on provoque pas
systématiquement
des réunions décisionnaires,
ou on s'en sort pas et on est pas
dans les temps qu'on veut.
Donc là, moi, j'ai donné un vert,
il est valable maintenant,
sauf si, à un moment donné,
on voit que la météo s'est dégradée,
la manoeuvre change,
l'ennemi change,
c'est pas ce qu'on avait prévu,
y a un changement de planification
et ce changement de planification
impacte toute la guerre,
à ce moment-là,
on retravaille, on replanifie,
mais sinon, c'est bon, OK ?
-Février 2023,
dans le sud de la France,
début des opérations,
l'exercice Orion est lancé.
-Cet exercice est un jalon
dans la nature des entraînements
conduits jusqu'à présent
et il acte le fait que nous avons
changé de contexte stratégique,
que nous sommes désormais
dans un contexte avec des conflits
beaucoup plus durs, on le voit,
aujourd'hui, à l'est de l'Europe,
entre l'Ukraine et la Russie.
Donc c'est ce que nous avons acté,
c'est la nature des changements
des conflits et le fait
que nous devons
nous entraîner pour des guerres
que nous pensions oubliées,
improbables,
qui le sont redevenues.
Musique intrigante
-C'est tout l'enjeu de l'exercice.
Le scénario :
l'attaque d'un pays fictif, Arnland,
par son voisin, Mercure,
appuyé par des milices.
L'exercice se joue en quatre phases.
Orion a démarré
par une campagne aéromaritime
d'entrée en premier,
autrement dit la projection
amphibie et aéroportée
de forces armées
sur le territoire déstabilisé.
-C'est une capacité
qui est difficile
à acquérir,
parce qu'elle nécessite
un certain nombre
de savoir-faire techniques
et de savoir-faire tactiques
très complets,
notamment ce qu'on appelle
de la projection de puissance,
donc la capacité à frapper
le dispositif ennemi
dans la profondeur
avant de projeter nos forces,
avions, soldats ou bateaux.
Toute nation n'en est pas capable,
la France fait partie
des rares pays
dans le monde à être capable,
justement,
de mener ce type d'opérations
parce qu'elle dispose des troupes
entraînées pour le faire
et surtout des moyens pour le faire,
que ce soit des moyens
de projection aériens,
ou des moyens
de projection maritimes.
-Orion est destiné à préparer
les armées aux combats
de haute intensité
contre un ennemi de même force.
-Pour comprendre ce qu'est
la haute intensité,
je pense qu'il faut aller
un peu dans la sémantique
de la physique, c'est-à-dire que,
la haute intensité,
c'est le quotient
de l'énergie et de la durée,
c'est-à-dire
qu'on imagine l'énergie,
c'est la violence,
c'est les feux,
c'est les pertes matérielles
et humaines associées,
et la durée, bah,
plus cette violence
est appliquée longtemps,
plus les pertes sont importantes
et posent des difficultés à un pays,
à une nation.
-Alors, les guerres
inter-étatiques avaient
vraiment disparu,
c'est-à-dire que le format,
c'était plus un contingent
expéditionnaire,
le format OPEX
pour les armées françaises,
un petit contingent qui va venir,
appelé par un autre Etat,
de façon à le renforcer
face à un acteur donc non-étatique,
un groupe armé terroriste, les GAT,
comme vu dans l'opération Barkhane.
Ici, on s'est préparé,
y compris dans le vocabulaire,
au retour de la haute intensité,
depuis donc
la décennie 2010,
en particulier
dans la suite des printemps arabes,
avec les conflits qu'on a vus
au Moyen-Orient, qui,
là, déjà n'étaient plus
vraiment contre-insurrectionnels,
on voyait émerger quand même
un type de conflit
avec le retour de la bataille
en zone urbaine,
et puis là, février 2022,
ça marquait ce retour
de la guerre en Europe,
au format inter-étatique.
Là, c'est quelque chose
d'assez inédit,
pour comparer,
cette date de fin février 2022,
pour l'Europe, elle est comparable
au 11 septembre américain
en 2001 parce que c'est le retour
d'un format de guerre
qui a tous les attraits
d'un format historique,
donc quelque chose qu'on a connu
au 20e siècle en Europe.
-Orion a été conçu
lors de l'année 2019-2020,
donc il faut pas chercher forcément
à comparer la situation
que l'on cherche
à reproduire dans l'exercice Orion
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en Ukraine,
c'est pas tout à fait l'objectif.
En revanche,
on a regardé la façon
dont le conflit
se déroule en Ukraine
et y a certainement
des séquences tactiques
sur le terrain qui doivent
nous interpeller.
Donc toutes ces composantes
du conflit,
bien évidemment,
on les a analysées, séquencées,
de façon à tester nos capacités,
confronter nos capacités,
lors de l'exercice Orion,
à ces différents défis.
-Les conflits armés
dans un format inter-étatique
correspondant aux caractéristiques
de haute intensité,
dans la période récente,
ils sont difficiles à trouver.
On est contraints de regarder
plus loin dans l'histoire,
les batailles de la Seconde Guerre,
en particulier le front de l'est,
avec déjà ces villes d'Ukraine
au centre des affrontements,
mais aussi lors de la Première
Guerre mondiale car plus ce conflit
de haute intensité
s'inscrit dans la durée,
plus les moyens
hautement technologiques
sont difficiles à produire,
en raison du temps,
et plus on va revenir à un format
classique d'affrontement,
c'est ainsi qu'on voit
revenir l'artillerie
comme reine des batailles
en Ukraine.
Jusqu'à la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
jusqu'à l'apparition
de la dissuasion nucléaire,
le modèle typique de guerre,
et vous remontez jusque
dans l'Antiquité,
c'était l'affrontement
entre cités-Etats,
l'affrontement entre Etats,
entre armées,
y compris avec des mercenaires,
et là, c'est encore une autre
histoire de la guerre.
-Depuis la fin des années 1990,
des décennies
de combats asymétriques
ou les opérations de stabilisation
et de lutte contre
le terrorisme ont été
la priorité pour les armées.
Elles se préparent désormais
à vivre des conflits plus durs
qui s'exerceraient dans tous
les domaines de la conflictualité,
que les militaires
nomment multi-milieux
multi-champs.
-C'est une façon de théoriser
l'espace de bataille.
C'est-à-dire que,
des trois dimensions
géographiques naturelles,
le milieu maritime,
aérien et terrestre,
on a finalement ajouté
d'autres dimensions.
On a ajouté déjà
deux milieux que sont
le milieu cyber
et le milieu spatial,
et deux champs,
le champ informationnel
et le champ électromagnétique,
qui est certainement le moins connu,
peut-être le plus difficile
à appréhender et donc on est passé
de trois à sept dimensions.
On s'aperçoit, avec les capacités,
les prouesses technologiques,
qu'on est capable d'exploiter
les milieux de façon beaucoup
plus étendue que par le passé,
ce qui, en termes de conflictualité,
fait peser forcément des menaces
supplémentaires.
-L'exercice intègre cette dimension
multi-milieux multi-champs
à tout niveau,
de l'état-major
jusque sur le terrain.
-Dans une opération,
il y a trois niveaux de décision.
On se trouve ici au niveau opératif,
dont la principale difficulté
est la coordination
des actions que peuvent conduire
toutes les composantes
contribuant à la manoeuvre :
terre, air, mer,
cyber, spatial, logistique
et dans le domaine
de la lutte informationnelle,
sans oublier les forces spéciales.
-C'est l'une des nouveautés.
Les militaires s'entraînent
pour la première fois
grandeur nature
à la guerre informationnelle.
Dans le camp ennemi,
tous les coups sont permis.
...
-Moi, je dispose d'un compte,
sur le réseau social,
pour chacun des deux ennemis
que j'incarne
et également d'un site Internet,
un espace presse,
où je publie des communiqués.
La particularité de ces canaux,
c'est que...
et c'est l'intérêt pour le joueur,
c'est que je ne m'applique pas
les règles que s'appliquent
les armées françaises.
Je suis un ennemi qui n'a pas
un fonctionnement démocratique,
pour entraîner les forces.
L'ennemi s'autorise diverses choses,
il fait déjà de la propagande
en déployant
des narratifs hostiles à la France,
pour la déstabiliser,
des narratifs de menaces.
L'objectif est de gagner
les coeurs et les esprits,
et donc d'influencer une population,
qu'elle soit hostile à la France.
-Nous avons constaté,
au cours des dernières années,
en particulier au Sahel
et en Afrique,
que, si nous n'y prenions pas garde,
certaines manipulations
de l'information se traduisent
de manière très concrète
dans le champ physique
par des entraves
à notre liberté d'action,
j'en veux pour preuve
l'exemple du convoi Voie sacrée,
un convoi logistique,
qui cheminait entre Abidjan et Gao,
en novembre 2021,
bloqué à plusieurs reprises
sur le simple fait d'accusations
portées contre l'armée française,
qui consistaient à dire
que ce convoi transportait
des munitions
et de l'armement pour les GAT,
et donc, les populations,
qui croyaient
à ces fausses informations,
voulaient contrôler le convoi,
ce qui était bien sûr impossible,
question de sécurité.
-On a vu se développer,
c'est donc un usage
planifié et coordonné,
en particulier
par des acteurs comme Wagner,
des acteurs russes,
tout simplement,
qui vont industrialiser
la production des informations
et qui vont donc faire
de l'outil Internet,
du smartphone, une arme,
c'est-à-dire que la désinformation
va venir vous toucher
jusque dans votre écran personnalisé
et va vous enfermer
dans une bulle informationnelle
qui sera renforcée
par les algorithmes.
L'idée, c'est de trouver les moyens
de percer cette bulle dans laquelle
n'importe quel type de citoyens,
y compris nos soldats,
nos militaires,
pourront être soumis
à de l'influence
et pourront voir le doute
s'instiller en eux
en raison de cette désinformation.
...
-Tout au long de l'exercice,
les militaires sont plongés
dans un environnement
numérique et informationnel
simulé pour l'occasion.
...
-La lutte informationnelle
dans Orion,
c'est quelque chose
de complètement expérimental,
qu'on teste grâce à l'appui
de la société Crisotech,
qui nous a mis à disposition
des outils et des plates-formes
pour pouvoir simuler et animer
cet environnement informationnel.
C'est la première fois
que l'on opère, que l'on génère
un tel environnement
dans le cadre d'un exercice,
la première fois,
on est jamais allés aussi loin
dans la simulation et l'animation
de l'environnement,
de la lutte informationnelle.
Nous, on est là pour mettre
en place la simulation
de l'environnement informationnel
et l'animer.
On anime du côté des rouges
et aussi sur l'intégralité
du spectre
informationnel
avec les opinions publiques,
les journaux français,
les médias, etc.
Tout ça fonctionne
avec à peu près 25 000 robots
qui fonctionnent
sur la plate-forme
et qui ont généré depuis le début
de l'exercice
282 000 réactions sur le système.
-Sur le terrain,
des actions médiatiques,
auxquelles s'ajoutent
des pressions
psychologiques de l'adversaire,
comme des manifestations,
des tags ou l'envoi de tracts.
-La première chose
qu'on attend d'une unité
qui constate, à son niveau,
qu'elle a été victime
d'actions d'intoxication,
c'est qu'elle rende compte
qu'elle a vu quelque chose, voilà.
Donc concrètement,
physiquement,
des joueurs sont équipés
de téléphones portables,
dédiés, spécifiques,
pour capter des images
intéressantes,
qui puissent être réutilisées
par l'échelon au-dessus,
tactique, stratégique,
et c'est à partir de l'analyse,
et donc de l'analyse qui va
permettre de déterminer
la dangerosité
de la fausse information,
que l'on va mettre en place
des stratégies de contrage
qui vont permettre d'élaborer
des messages qui vont contrer
la fausse information adverse.
-En fait, produire du contenu,
ça revient à mener
des actions très différentes.
Il y a la capacité à documenter
ce que nous faisons,
avec un enjeu de transparence,
voire de rapidité, c'est-à-dire
être capable de très vite
produire des images preuves
pour démonter des accusations,
ce qu'on a fait
avec le charnier de Gossi,
en 2022,
où nous avons mis en évidence
une attaque informationnelle
contre les armées françaises
menée par les mercenaires de Wagner,
et la meilleure arme contre ça,
c'est la liberté de la presse,
permettre
au journaliste de faire son travail.
...
-Orion permet aussi de travailler
l'interopérabilité
avec plusieurs des partenaires
de la France tout comme la capacité
à tenir le rôle de nation cadre,
un enjeu crucial
pour la haute intensité.
...
-Agir en coalition,
c'est agir avec des alliés,
soit au sein de l'alliance
atlantique ou de l'UE,
soit au sein d'une coalition
qu'on dit ad hoc,
c'est-à-dire avec des pays qui,
pour la circonstance,
sont prêts à agir avec nous,
comme on le fait par exemple
dans un certain nombre de théâtres,
et être nation cadre,
c'est être la nation qui va
commander l'opération et qui,
notamment, va fournir
les moyens de commandement
pour commander l'opération.
Ca relève des capacités
rares dont disposent
les armées françaises.
-Effectivement,
pour ce genre d'opérations,
qui sont extrêmement lourdes,
extrêmement complexes,
on ne pourra le faire
qu'avec des alliés.
On a tous des capacités
assez phénoménales,
assez énormes,
mais, seulement,
l'intégration de chacune
de ces capacités
au sein d'un commandement unique,
qu'il soit français, dans ce cas,
puisque nous sommes nation cadre,
"permettront" de vaincre
un adversaire
avec la masse suffisante.
-Sur les 12 000 militaires
commandés par le général Gaulin
pour la phase
d'affrontement
dans l'est de la France,
1700 soldats sont étrangers,
de 14 nationalités différentes,
un engagement inédit.
-A l'issue,
nous aurons 30 minutes
de chargement.
-Les opérations
de combat à grande échelle
sont les plus complexes à mener,
si nous pouvons les maîtriser,
nous pourrons opérer
à n'importe quel niveau,
y compris les opérations d'urgence,
de stabilité et de soutien.
Si nous avons appris
quelque chose de l'histoire,
c'est que les alliances
sont cruciales.
Nous vivons dans un monde
de plus en plus interconnecté,
diplomatiquement,
politiquement, socialement,
économiquement et militairement.
Ces exercices nous permettent
de développer l'interopérabilité
et la compréhension pour tirer,
se déplacer et communiquer.
Le plus nous nous entraînons,
nous nous comprenons,
tant sur le plan culturel
que dans nos systèmes,
le mieux nous sommes en mesure
de combattre ensemble,
en tant qu'alliés.
-OK, les gars, je vous explique.
Un petit pays comme la Belgique,
on va très rarement
s'engager tout seul,
on fait en général partie
d'une coalition et pour ça,
il faut s'entraîner ensemble,
encore et encore,
pour mettre en place des procédures
et des passerelles techniques
pour communiquer.
Et ça ne peut se faire
qu'avec de l'entraînement régulier.
L'interopérabilité,
on pense aux radios,
où on doit pouvoir
se parler,
communiquer entre nous,
mais c'est beaucoup plus,
c'est avant tout interpersonnel.
Il faut comprendre
avec qui on va travailler
pour comprendre
les différences culturelles
et pouvoir finalement collaborer
et tirer le meilleur profit
de chacun pour être meilleur à deux
que chacun séparément.
-Les armées y travaillent.
-Bien au-delà
du seul enjeu militaire,
le défi est national.
Orion intègre aussi
une dimension civile,
autrement dit
les services de l'Etat pouvant être
touchés par le conflit imaginé,
pour étudier
leur capacité à résister
et à soutenir les armées.
-Les enjeux politiques et sociaux
de la préparation
à la haute intensité,
on les synthétise en une notion,
un concept, qui est celui
de résilience de la nation,
l'idée principale étant,
de cette résilience,
que, en dépit
d'une attaque puissante,
forte, rapide,
d'un acteur doté
de toutes ces composantes,
notre Etat,
nos forces soient capables
de résister
à cette première attaque.
-C'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles,
dans l'exercice Orion,
au tout début,
il a été imaginé
une phase civilo-militaire,
parce qu'il était évident,
pour les concepteurs
de l'exercice,
qu'on ne pouvait pas se projeter
dans cette fiction
avec simplement
un engagement militaire,
il fallait penser la mobilisation
nationale tout autour.
C'est intéressant,
on est venu à la rencontre
d'une initiative
du secrétariat général de la Défense
et de la Sécurité nationale,
qui travaillait
sur la stratégie nationale
de résilience.
-Monsieur le directeur de cabinet,
merci de nous faire
l'honneur de votre présence
pour cet exercice
interministériel,
qui est majeur,
qui s'inscrit effectivement
dans l'exercice Orion
et qui avait pour objectif
de marquer que,
aux côtés du ministère des Armées,
cheville ouvrière
de l'exercice Orion,
l'ensemble de l'Etat,
les administrations centrales,
mais aussi les administrations
territoriales
et les collectivités locales,
et les citoyens,
et les associations doivent pouvoir
se mettre en ordre de bataille
pour pouvoir soutenir
un effort de guerre
qui, à la fois,
aura lieu à l'extérieur
mais aurait aussi un impact
sur notre territoire national
et sur le fonctionnement
de notre société.
-Je pense que l'aptitude d'un Etat
à s'imposer face à ses compétiteurs,
adversaires, ennemis
ne dépend pas uniquement
de la compétence de ses armées,
c'est aussi la performance
de l'appareil d'Etat
qui conditionnera le succès.
-On a découvert,
durant la crise COVID,
après les tâtonnements du début,
que notre pays, notre société,
notre peuple avaient
des ressources extraordinaires
pour s'organiser, se coordonner
et faire en sorte que,
même en confinement,
on arrivait toujours à se nourrir,
à se soigner et avoir un certain
nombre de services rendus.
Sur un conflit en haute intensité,
ça doit être la même chose.
Ca va des sujets juridiques,
est-ce qu'on réquisitionne
ou on fait des contrats ?
Quel est le cadre juridique ?
Ca va des sujets logistiques,
quelles entreprises sont capables
de fournir des camions,
des trains, des avions ?
Ca va sur des sujets stock.
On a beaucoup parlé
d'économie de guerre,
dans l'économie de guerre,
vous avez deux dimensions.
Vous avez d'abord la nécessité
que l'industrie de défense
soit capable de produire plus,
plus vite,
en de meilleures circonstances,
ce qui veut dire que, en droit,
on puisse modifier les textes
pour lui permettre de travailler
plus et de fournir plus.
Et puis après,
il y a l'autre aspect
qui est justement
d'organiser notre économie,
de corriger nos règles
de marché public
pour faire en sorte que,
face à une situation exceptionnelle,
une situation d'urgence,
on puisse être
en situation
d'agir et de réagir vite,
de ne pas se retrouver coincés
par des normes ou des procédures
qui sont utiles et même nécessaires
en temps de paix mais qui,
en temps de crise, entravent,
font perdre du temps
et risquent de coûter des vies.
-Deux passes et demie,
juste sur la butée !
A cinq mètres,
je sais pas si y a un mort ou pas.
-En sus de l'adaptation, du droit,
des normes, Orion permet de mesurer
l'importance
des réserves nationales,
un renfort jugé indispensable
dans un scénario de haute intensité.
De nombreux réservistes ont été
mobilisés pendant l'exercice.
-Bah, c'est une grande
chance d'être là,
et, bah, on a travaillé
avec la brigade cynophile,
donc on a eu beaucoup
de ressentis de...
des militaire là-bas,
on a eu beaucoup d'informations
sur ce qu'ils faisaient.
J'ai découvert des régiments,
j'ai découvert
comment ils travaillaient,
comment ça se mettait en place,
comment ils se répartissaient
sur des camps et comment
ils travaillaient sur le terrain.
Je vois ça pour la première fois.
C'est super important
d'avoir des réservistes,
surtout au sein de ces exercices,
parce qu'on est le premier lien
entre la vie civile et l'armée,
la nation et l'armée.
Ca nous permet
de parler au quotidien
à des gens de tous les jours
qui connaissent pas
du tout l'armée,
de les sensibiliser,
parce qu'on peut avoir beaucoup
d'a priori sur l'armée.
Et puis les gens, en fait,
ils nous posent des questions,
on leur répond
parce qu'on est dedans.
Là, je vais pouvoir
leur répondre un peu plus
parce que je connais
un peu mieux le terrain
et tous les régiments ici.
-Léo est étudiant
dans l'audiovisuel.
Matthieu vient de terminer
des études de finance
et souhaite s'engager.
Réserviste depuis un an,
ils se sont portés volontaires
pour participer à l'exercice.
-En tant que réserviste,
nous servons de différentes façons,
des missions telles que
des check-points pour contrôler
les véhicules de la force ennemie,
ou de surveillance de zone,
de renseignement,
des missions de combat
avec des actions où il faut
s'emparer, par exemple,
de cages de munitions,
ou d'aller au contact directement.
Ce qui m'a beaucoup plu,
dans la mission Orion,
c'est principalement
de travailler avec les alliés,
britanniques,
américains, belges et autres,
de voir différents véhicules
que nous n'avons pas,
réservistes,
l'occasion de voir souvent
et de vivre
des missions de haute intensité,
j'aime beaucoup.
-Les réservistes sont des gens,
pas importants,
ils sont essentiels, en fait,
pour notre exercice
mais pour notre vie
de tous les jours
et nos opérations en général.
J'en ai de l'ordre de 1000,
ici, sur l'opération.
Alors, plusieurs rôles.
Dans un premier temps,
j'ai beaucoup d'officiers,
sous-officiers d'état-major,
qui sont des spécialistes
dans certains domaines,
qui sont complètement intégrés
dans les états-majors,
que ce soit au niveau
du corps d'armée, de la division,
des brigades
et au niveau des régiments.
Et, deuxième temps,
j'ai des unités
de réservistes qui ont
des missions de protection,
des missions d'intervention.
Ils ont des savoir-faire
qui sont très utiles,
qui sont en train de se durcir,
tout comme l'armée d'actifs
se durcit,
notre réserve est
en train de se durcir,
mais c'est effectivement
une composante
absolument critique pour nous.
Musique planante
-Le ministère des Armées
compte 40 000 réservistes
opérationnels.
...
Ce nombre devrait doubler
dans les prochaines années.
Orion s'est achevé
au début du mois de mai,
après trois semaines d'affrontement
dans les plaines du Grand Est.
La France compte
renouveler l'opération
tous les trois ans,
prochaine étape, donc,
l'année 2026 pour une nouvelle
édition de cet exercice.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...